what do you think is the coolest
invention humans come up with
the wheel
fire
cooking meat
computer computers computers freaking
computers internet or computers which
one what do you think the previous
technologies i mean may have even been
more profound and moved us to a certain
degree but i think the computers are
what make us homotech know i think this
is what it's a brain augmentation
and and so it like allows for actual
evolution like the computers accelerate
the degree to which all the other
technologies can also be accelerated
would you classify yourself as a homo
sapien or a homotechnology definitely
homotec now
so i think we're all you're you're one
of the earliest of the species i think
most of us are like i i like as i said
like i think if you
um
like
looked at brain scans of us versus um
humans 100 years ago it would look very
different i think we are physiologically
different just even the interaction with
the devices has changed outbreaks well
and if you look at um a lot of studies
are coming out to show that like
there's a degree of inherited memory so
some of these physiological changes in
theory should be we should be passing
them on
so like
that's you know that's not like a
an instance of physiological change
that's going to fizzle out in theory
that should progress
like to our offspring
you